ne
[Müzik]
duyduysan
Hoş geldiniz gerçekten heyecanlı içeride
Beklerken daha da heyecanlandık Ama
buraya gelince daha Hem rahat hem
heyecanlı ikisi bir arada dönüşüm elinde
yazıyor size en iyi bildiğim şeyi
anlatacağım kendi hikayemi
ama yani bir kız çocuğu olarak
1978 yılında doğmuş
Yeliz Gül anlatacağım
neye dönüştüğünü anlatacağım
bu
78 yılı Kemer
şu andaki gibi bir kemer Hayal etmeyin
elektrik yokk ve
Ataerkil kız çocuğunun doğması bit
program
o
Özellikle de Soylu bir ailenin ilk
çocuğunun kız olması biraz problem Çünkü
soy devam etmeli Eğer ilki erkek olursa
soy cepte
değer ilki kızsa biraz daha deneme lazım
Doğru mu ve 1978 yılında Ben de uyuyorum
soğuk bir Aralık gününü zor bir doğum
anacım bir gün sonra benim kız oldum
öğreniyor bakın çok büyük bir olay babam
zaten sormuyor bile Çünkü bütün
Hamilelik boyunca beni oğlum diye
seviyor şu
O bizim dönemimizde burada benimle yaşıt
insanlar var dayak Cennetten çıkmadır
arkadaşlar
Bugün dayak hak ediliyordu
o öretmen döverdi evde ana baba döverdi
anne en hafifi terlik çiğdi ama ben
gerçekten sağlam dayak yedim şımarık bir
çocuk olduğum için Haylaz bir çocuk
olduğum için değil
bir Rahmetli babamın stresini attı bir
çocuk olarak dayak yedim
Ya
normalde diyorum o yüzden böyle abuk
subuk hikayeleri falan da girmek
istemiyorum
hak ediyorduk diyelim Bu da geçti
bu en zor geliyor arkadaşlar
dönüşümün başladığı zamanlar bir şekilde
harala gürele amca oğullarıyla onla
bunla bir şekilde erkek gibi bir hayat
geçiyor ama bir noktaya geliyoruz
bu nokta benim zannedersem mücadelenin
başladığı nokta
o Çünkü
ilköğretim Kemer Merkez
ortaokul 5 artı 3 o zaman Kemer Merkez
Ortaokulu ama liseye geldiğimizde ne
oldu biliyor musunuz o kadının yeter sen
kızsın
de okumayacaksın bakın Biz ilkokul
mezunu yüz anan baban olarak
O senin de ortaokula kadar oldu bitti
hadi paydos
Ee Nasıl yapacağız Nasıl bunu ikna
edeceğiz Elbette Annem de çalışıyor Bu
konuda bu tanıdıklar araya giriyor
akrabalar devreye giriyor Babam kabul
ediyor ama devlet okulu olmaz diyor
güvenli olsun peki Antalya'ya geliş
gidişler başlıyor ortada bir özel kolej
Ee Benim kardeşim benden 4 yaş küçük bir
erkek yani İkincide gole vurmuş Baba
ama o çocuk cihaza şöyle bir bana göre
kötülük ettiler 5 sınıfa başladı Ben
liseye başladım ya ablana bekçilik
yapacaksın diye onu beş sınıfta aldılar
Sudan Çıkmış balık gibi İngilizce
eğitime verdiler Yani benim de bitti O
da başladı
bekçim var gidip geliyorum güvenliğim
Okey her şey güzel sonra Türkçe
Matematik Bölümü bir düşünce olmuş
normal problem yok Üniversite geldi
kapıyı çaldı üniversite okudun mu sizce
Benim Babam
Bu mümkün değil mümkün değil gidiyorum
Dershane her akşam evde bir baba
çalış ama gitmeyeceksin göndermeyeceğim
bunlara rağmen ben oturup Nasılsa
kazanamayacağım deyip çalışmaya bilirdim
hep bunu anlatıyorum gittiğim okullarda
da ben çalıştım bir şekilde onu ikna
ederiz dedim ve ettik mi biraz zor oldu
ama ettik
bu Üniversite Uludağ Üniversitesi
İktisadi İdari Bilimler Bu arada babam
bana Antalya Akdeniz yaz dedi Ben
Akdeniz iç yazmadım Çünkü Akdeniz
Koleji'nde okuyorum Camdan baktım da
Akdeniz Üniversitesi görüyorum dört tane
binası Var Hayat doğru okumam diyorum
haberi yok tabii Ben tercihleri yaptım
aşkım sonra Bursa'yı seçtim İzmir seçtim
Ankara'ya seçtim çünkü İstanbul'u zaten
olsa da göndermez
aradım dokuz numarayı Biz de o zaman
öyle kadın okuyor Uludağ Üniversitesi
yavaş yavaş sade İdari Bilimler Aha
dedim kazandım gittim Baba kazandım
Tamam göndermiyorum dedi Allah'ım dedim
ya nasıl olur Ya arkadaş Millet gidiyor
kazanamıyor ben nasıl gidemem gideceğim
tabii Çünkü çok büyük bir benim için
Challenge bu yani kazandım gideceğim
dershaneye hocalara yalvar ona yalvar
buna yalvar çok şeydir böyle Aslında
başkalarının sözünü dinler ve ben
harçlığımı iyi dinle de beni bir şekilde
Uludağ Üniversitesine kaybettirdi sonra
dört yıl sonra bir telefon daha aldım o
zaman cep telefonu falan yok Bölüm
başkanımız Tahir başlarımız Profesör
Doktor Yeliz kızım bölüm birincisi
olduğunu dedi çalışma ekonomisi
mezunuyum oldu hocam dedim kimse gelmedi
okula dedim ben nasıl birinci oldum
babamı aradım baba dedim ben bölüm
birincisi olmuşum gelmek ister misin
tabi geliriz dedi tören severler
verdiler
sonra o törenden sonra Tabi ki de birşey
oldu ne oldu biliyor musunuz dönüşüm
babamda ama Hani derler ya İnsan
yedisinde yetmişinde aynıdır diye değil
arkadaşlar öyle bir şey yok öyle diye
bir şey yok Benim oğlanı sözüyle öyle
bir şey yok babam bana şu soruyu sordu
yükseğini yapacak mısın
Bu yan taraftaki görselde oğlum Arsel'in
bir kitabından belli with love it and
with Yani inan yaşa ve ol Tam öyle bir
vücut buldum ben o anda tabi yapacağım
dedim
E tabi yapacağım kaçırmayın bu fırsatı
döndüm hemen
Antalya Akdeniz Üniversitesi'ne
O hep içimde şu vardı Ben okuldan mezun
olurken de Bölüm Başkanı hocamıza dedim
ki hocam bana kartınız attı İktisadi
Bilimler işte Bölüm Başkanı yazıyor Hiç
böyle bir kart veremeyeceğim de Neden
kızım dedi hocam dedim ben dedim Babamın
Kızıyım işte gideceğim yer belli babam o
zaman pansiyondan bozma Otel sahibi
Kemer'de burada onun başına geçeceğim
dedim Böyle deme olur mu O da bir iş
falan dedi Sağ ol hocam dedim Ee sonra
Akdeniz Üniversitesi'nde Turizm
Otelcilik ve işletme Bölümü'nde Master
başladım ama bu arada bunu Astra
başlarkenki bir kısa dönemin var Ben o
dönemde çalışmak istedi
Ama babam Kazım bil
bu yaz günü kızı çalışamaz dedi Ayıp
sarı sayfalar oluşturuluyor altın rehber
gibi izce görüşmeye git
bu iş görüşmesine bir baktım abicim iş
bana göre işte çevrene üye yapacağım
sayfalara yazdıracağım Babam da çevre
Gani herkesi koyarım ben o güzel sonra
kısa süreli bir iş bitti ya Geldim Baba
ben iş buldum anlatırım böyle
O ne dedi iş görüşmesine mi gittin
Ama dönmedi çok şükür Ama dövmekten
beter etti Ben aradım gelemiyorum Kusura
bakmayın nazikçe Kazım benim kızı
çalışamıyor bitti Sonra ne yaptım
üniversiteye başladım yüksek lisansa
Onun haberi bile yok ben dedim ki plan
be devreye girdi
devlette iş bulursam bu dedim Eski
Toprak devlete izin verir özel izin
vermiyor Güven duymuyor devlete izin
verir haberi bile yok gittim sosyal
bilimlere kadro başvurusunda bulundum
bu ve Akdeniz Üniversitesi'nde araştırma
görevlisi oldu Dört yıl çalıştım bir
sürü öğrencim var bu izin verdi Tabii ki
verdi yani onu
boşlukları ile yakalamaya çalıştım çünkü
aksini çok ısrar ederseniz olmuyor
Arkadaşlar bir yerde Siz çözüme odaklı
yaşayacaksınız okutmuyor mu başka çözüm
bulacaksınız birileriyle devreye
gireceksiniz
Bu çalışmanın sonrasında dört yıl geçti
arkadaşlar 4 yıl sonra vicdan yaptım
o Çünkü ben onun kızıyım
ne olursa olsun onunla birlikte olmam
lazım bizim için bir gelecek hazırladı
düşüncesine Ben istifamı verdim
rektörlükte kadıncağız camın altından
şöyle baktı bana öğrenci işlerinde e
memurluktan istifa mı ediyorsunuz dedi
Evet istifa ediyorum dedim Ve ben
babamın yanına döndüm macera başlıyor
ikincisi He ünvanı olmayan bir işim oldu
arkadaşlar olduğu belli değil ben
muhasebe de oturuyorum üç gün Oturuyorum
öyle bakıyorum ama fatura geliyor satın
alma gidiyor Para geliyor çalışan
çıkıyor izliyorum ama iki haftada bir
Babamın yanındayım Baba ben ne zaman bir
şey başına olacağım duracağım Baba sen
oturur da kızım sen orada otur öyle otur
ya adam fark etmeden Ben fark etmeden
Meğer beni işletmenin kalbine koymuş ve
her şeyi o öğrenmemi sağlamış Ama ben
onu kötülük yaptığımı düşünüyorum hemen
bir Titan hemen bir kartvizitin her
şeyim olmalı ama öyle olmadı bu
ama ben oraya başladıktan sonra Okuldan
geri döndükten sonra
bir şeyler yapmaya çalışıyorum Allah her
gün okulda öğrendiğim şeyleri
organizasyon şemaları çiziyorum çok
acayip Çünkü tek tabanca Babam hiçbir
şey izin vermiyor logomuzu eski onu
değiştireyim bunu Değiştireyim ben
yanıyorum tutuşuyorum Ama hiç oralı
olmuyor Babam işte benim hayatımda Davut
Başkan size İnan Kıraç dedi ya ben de
Suna Kıraç diyorum o kadın benim
babamdan sonra rol modeli Allah rahmet
eylesin her ikisine de
iş hayatında çok sıkıldım ve gerçekten
babamın tek tabanca olmasından dolayı
Hiçbir şey yapmadığım yapamadığım
dönemlerde bir abim geldi Dedi ki bana
sen niye bu kadar kendini yoruyorsun ya
dedi sen dedi ben sana bir kitap verecek
onu bir okul Tamam dedim açtım kitabı
kitap bu okuyorum ah
bu Koskoca Vehbi Koç'un kızı Suna Kıraç
ta kız çocuk olarak doğduğu için benim
gibi sıkıntılar yaşamış ve babasıyla
çalışırken de Suna aynı benim gibi
durumlara maruz kalmış ve onun
yöntemleri olmuş aynılarını yaptım
O ne oldu babam konuştu konuşma
notlarını alıp hayata geçirdim ertesi
gün ben demedim bunu benim haberim yok
diyen aynı Vehbi Koç gibi babamdı ona
mektup yazmışsın ama ben de Mektup
yazdım bu ne dedi mektup dedim Dün
konuştuklarımız böyle böyle böyle böyle
bir yerlere geldik ama babam bir yerlere
geldiğimizde bir gün bana şuna söyle
İyisin hoşsun ama kadınsın be yavrum
bankacılarla görüşmeye giremem
acentalarla görüşmelere giremem kadınım
Çünkü gerçekten böyle şaka gibi ama
böyle
hiç bakmadık mücadeleyi bırakmadık Bu
arada Sivil Toplum Örgütü görevlerin
başladı Az önce ilk konuşmacı mız Davut
başkanı anlattı hayatını yüzde 60'ında
ki STK ları herhalde ben
birlikte çalıştığımız için şahidim 2007
yılında Antalya Ticaret Odasına bir
girdim ben de 10 11 yıl civarı orada
görev yaptım Bunun yanında farklı
kurumlarda da bulundum Ama bu arada İki
tane evladım oldu Allah bağışlarsa
Babam bana dedi ki kızım
İlkinde pes edersin dedim etmedin
ikincisinde dedim onda da etmedin daha
ben artık seni bıraktım dedi bak ben
ikinciden sonra özgürleşti bu sene 2015
2015'e kadar mücadele devam etti Hiç
öyle
anlattığım gibi kolay olmadı Her gün
başka bir mücadele Her gün başka bir
gözyaşı Camdan bir duvar Normalde kakara
kikiri olduğun adam Canım Babam dedin
öptüğün adam gittiğinde bambaşka işte
Ama
bir gün Radyo programına katıldım
üniversite FM
da aynı hocam var Aker
o konuştu konuştu karar verdik ama ben
böyle gene anlatıyorum hocam dedim ben
bir şey fark ettim o gün bir aydınlandım
şu bu ne fark ettin Ben size anlatıyorum
Ne dedim hep babam babam babam
Evet
hocam babam bana engeller koyarak Meğer
motivasyon yaratmış Ben bunu fark ettim
dedi
var ya Yani sadece engel olarak görmeyin
Sen bana engel koyma saydığı Belki ben
keyfekeder oturuyor ve yine Belki daha
iyi zenginlik Servet falan yaşıyordum
biliyor musunuz belki daha erken
evlenirdim Belki daha farklı bir hayatım
olurdu ama bunları bana engeller koyarak
herkesin motivasyonu inşaatlar
olmayabilir sanırım Benimkisi de
engellenmek ben onu gördüm ve 3
üniversite Kazım Gül Üniversitesi Aynen
Suna Kıraç'ın Vehbi Koç
Üniversitesi'nden mezun olmaya çalıştığı
gibi
bu iki kitap arkadaşlar hayatımı
değiştiren iki kitap Doğan Cüceloğlu
Savaşçı
o Çünkü bir kadın olarak kız çocuğu
olduk eş olduk anne olduk Ama benim için
çok önemli olan başka bir şey var Sadece
parayı kazandığınız yerde değil aynı
zamanda farklı insanlara rol model
olabileceğiniz yerlerde olmak bu da en
iyi sivil toplum örgütleri İşte o sivil
toplum örgütlerinde de bunu görmeye
başladım kitabın imzalı özellikle koydum
çünkü Doğan hocam rahmetli almak
istiyorum seni diğerlerinden farksız
yapmaya bütün gücüyle gece gündüz
çalışan bir dünyada kendin olarak
kalabilmek dünyanın en zor savaşını
vermek demektir Ama bu savaş bir başladı
mı artık hiç bitmiyor bu eğer o Ruha bir
kere girdiyseniz Gerçekten bundan
çıkmanız mümkün olmuyor Siz kendinize
her alanda Savaşı kendiniz
yaratıyorsunuz
bir
savaşçı gücünü kendini adadığı
Gelecekten alır
brevet Ben aslında çok fazla
kendimle ilgili bir misyon edilmedim bir
plan yapmadım ama hayat bana getirdi Ben
onları evire çevire dönüştüre Yaşamaya
çalıştım ve hala da yaşıyorum niyet mi
Çok önemli çünkü Siz iyi niyetliyseniz
dönüşümde de o iyiniyeti görürsünüz yani
şu içinizdeki kalbinizdeki iyi niyet çok
çok önemli bu her şeye yansıyor Ve ben
bunu hayatımda birebir görüyorum
ya bu kadar konuştuktan sonra onu
koymazsam olmazdı O Benim Birtanem ilk
aşkım Babam bu üç yıl oldu bizimle
vedalaştı yanındaki de kardeşim yani
dedim İkincide
soy devamını sağla ya Bildik diye
ve bu Ooo zorlandığım yıllardan
Özellikle o fotoğraf özellikle
ya ben tedex kaleiçine bu kadar zaman
sonra gayret edip motivasyon sağlayıp
kadar insanı bir araya getirdi Bizleri
bir araya getirdi çok ama çok teşekkür
ediyorum burada özellikle bir daha
keçisi var
bari içinizden hiç düşündünüz mü
bilmiyorum ben çok sık düşünüyorum Bu
hayvanlar ötürü herhangi bir hayvan
olsaydım ne olurdu diye düşündünüz mü
herhangi bir hayvan bakın Çünkü insanız
Tamam ama hayvan olsak ne olurduk Ben
kendime daha keçisini yakıştırıyorum
hayatımı onu yakıştırıyorum Çünkü
kesinlikle mücadeleci olmalıyız ve
inançlı olmalıyız
ve dik durmalıyız
o ve ben bu hayvan da onu çok görüyorum
o nedenle en son Sıla'yı da bir daha
keçisini koymak istedim Çok teşekkür
ediyorum
ve dinlediğiniz için
sağ ol